fine man's learning technique is
effective for learning something new
deepening your understanding of what you
already know or helping you study for an
exam the first step is to pick a topic
you want to understand and start
studying it once you know what it is
about take a piece of paper and write
about it as if you're teaching the idea
to someone else
ideally write and speak at the same time
just as a teacher does it if the blind
bored this makes you realize which part
you understand and where you still have
gaps
whenever you get stuck go back to study
and repeat that process until you have
explained the whole topic from start to
end when you're done repeat the process
from the beginning but this time
simplify your language or use a graphic
analogy to make a point if your
explanation ends up wordy or confusing
you probably have not understood it well
enough so you should start again
thinking about an idea by explaining it
makes this learning method very
effective once you can explain an idea
in simple language you have deeply
understood it and will remember it for a
long time Richard Fineman was a leading
theoretical physicist who received a
Nobel Prize for his work in quantum
electrodynamics he was notorious for
asking his fellow mathematicians to
explain concepts in simple language to
test their understanding
thanks for watching also check out other
sprouts learning techniques as they can
compliment the methods explained in this
video please use the comments below to
give us feedback or tell us which of the
techniques is your favorite